The following episode of How We Made Your Mother was recorded live on Instagram on February 4th, 2026.
以下这集《老爸老妈的浪漫史制作内幕》（How We Made Your Mother）于2026年2月4日在Instagram上进行直播。
We are live.
我们正在直播。
Oh, we are live on Instagram.
哦，我们在Instagram上直播呢。
It's happening.
开始了。
Hi.
嗨。
It's all happening.
全都开始了。
Hi Craig Thomas.
嗨，克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）。
Josh Radner and other people that we don't know.
乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）以及其他我们不认识的人。
Hello people who are joining us, Josh Radner.
大家好，欢迎加入我们的乔什·拉德纳。
This is my friend Craig Thomas.
这是我的朋友克雷格·托马斯。
Craig co-created a show called How I Met Your Mother with Carter Baze that I was on for nine years.
克雷格和卡特·贝斯（Carter Baze）共同创作了一部名叫《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的剧，我在这部剧里演了九年。
I played Ted Mosby on that show.
我在那部剧里扮演泰德·莫斯布（Ted Mosby）。
We're doing a podcast now called How We Made Your Mother where we're re-watching all of the episodes.
我们现在正在做一个名为《老爸老妈的浪漫史制作内幕》的播客，我们在重温所有剧集。
My wife, Jordana had never seen the show, so she wanted to watch it, and I called Craig, and I said, look, I'm gonna show my wife this show we made.
我妻子乔丹娜（Jordana）以前从未看过这部剧，所以她想看，我给克雷格打了电话，我说，听着，我要给我妻子看这部我们制作的剧。
Do you wanna do something a little more formal on the record?
你想不想做点更正式、更公开的事？
Maybe we can revisit it and talk about it, and that's what we've been doing.
也许我们可以重温并谈论它，这就是我们一直在做的事情。
We're two seasons deep.
我们已经播了两季了。
It's crazy.
太疯狂了。
We haven't, not all of the second season has dropped yet, but we are what, Alec, would you say, like early middle season two is currently dropping week by week?
我们还没——第二季还没全部上线，但是亚历克（Alec），你会怎么说，第二季的早期到中期目前是不是正在按周更新？
Something like that, producer Aklev here.
差不多吧，制作人亚历克在这里。
That's right.
没错。
we're in it.
我们正在播。
We are deep into season two and we want to do these IG Labs sometimes just to help get the word out and and find more people.
我们已经深入第二季了，我们有时想做这些Instagram直播，只是为了帮忙宣传并找到更多人。
I had this experience where I went into the how I met your mother bar in New York City.
我有过这样一次经历，我去了纽约市的那家《老爸老妈的浪漫史》主题酒吧。
It is the bar of how much mother because it's where Carter and I used to go to drink after taping late show with David Letterman when we were in our 20s when we were writers for that show.
这就是那家“老妈”酒吧，因为当我们二十多岁在《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》（Late Show with David Letterman）当编剧时，我和卡特录制完节目后经常去那里喝酒。
And I had the experience recently of going in there And the bartender at the bar, who's very nice, who I've known 13 years, said, are you doing a podcast?
我最近有了这样的经历：我走进酒吧，酒吧里非常友善的酒保——我认识她十三年了——说，你们在做播客吗？
She's like, Irish, you're doing a podcast?
她说，爱尔兰人，你们在做播客吗？
I didn't know, I'm like, if the bartender at the how much your mother bar doesn't know we're doing a podcast, we are shitting them if something is going wrong here.
我当时不知道，心想，如果“老爸老妈”酒吧的酒保都不知道我们在做播客，那我们这里肯定是出什么大问题了，太逊了。
So I was like, we gotta get the word out more.
所以我当时就想，我们得加大宣传力度。
Now, also though, we should be clear.
不过现在，我们也得说清楚。
There's a lot of people listening to the podcast.
其实有很多人在听这个播客。
It's just relative to the world of how I met your mother fans.
只是相对于《老爸老妈的浪漫史》粉丝的世界来说。
There's more people that we think would be enjoying this thing we're doing, right?
还有更多人我们觉得会喜欢我们正在做的这件事，对吧？
Yes, to be clear, we're happy with it as it is.
是的，说明白点，我们对现状很满意。
We just want it to be bigger.
我们只是希望它能更大一点。
And we want your questions.
我们需要你们的问题。
We want you to tell a friend, and it's very interactive.
我们希望你们能告诉身边的朋友，这个播客非常具有互动性。
It's very fan-forward, this podcast, right?
这个播客非常以粉丝为中心，对吧？
We started every episode with a voice note from a fan about what how I met your mother means to them.
我们每一集都以粉丝的语音留言开场，内容是关于《老爸老妈的浪漫史》对他们的意义。
We end every episode with a letter, a written letter from a viewer, a fan.
我们每一集都以一封信收尾，这是一位观众、一位粉丝写来的信。
And if you want to participate in that way, go to how we made your mother.com, h-w-m-y-m.com.
如果你想以这种方式参与，请访问 howwemakeyourmother.com，即 h-w-m-y-m.com。
Go to contact and just follow the directions.
点击“联系我们”（contact），然后按照说明操作。
you can either leave a voice note or an email.
你可以留下语音留言或发送电子邮件。
And maybe, there's a good chance your letter might end up on the air.
很有可能，你的信就会在节目中被读到。
What are we, what would you say guiding people?
我们在干嘛，你会怎么指导大家？
Like, what do we respond to in terms of the letters?
比如，我们在信件方面通常会回应什么？
Well, we ask, we ask episode specific, right?
嗯，我们要求，我们要求针对特定剧集，对吧？
Every week, Alex, Lab, that you are posting things that say, do you have any questions about, for example, this week is Monday Night Football.
每周，亚历克，直播时你都会发布一些消息，比如，你有没有关于——举个例子，这周是《周一橄榄球之夜》（Monday Night Football）。
That season two episode Monday Night Football.
也就是第二季的那个剧集《周一橄榄球之夜》。
Did you have any questions about that?
你们对那集有什么疑问吗？
And we just did it.
我们刚刚完成了那一集。
That's the one where they tried not to learn who won the Super Bowl for 24 hours.
就是他们试图在24小时内不去看谁赢了超级碗的那一集。
so they could watch it together.
这样他们就可以一起观看了。
The sensory depurator 5000, which is a device a lot of people wish they were wearing every day as the news rolls in, but we won't go there.
感官净化器5000（The sensory depurator 5000），这是许多人在每天新闻不断涌现时都希望佩戴的一台设备，不过我们就不展开说了。
I bet you could mark it.
我敢说你可以把它推向市场。
I bet we could sell in the premium gift shop.
我敢说我们可以在高级礼品店里卖它。
We could sell sensory depurator 3000.
我们可以出售感官净化器3000。
Here's your 2026 sensory depurator.
这是你的2026款感官净化器。
We'll see you in 27.
27年再见。
We'll see you check in again how it's going.
我们到时候再来看看进展如何。
Yeah.
对。
So we asked episode web.
所以我们询问的是关于剧集的问题。
So the more, Alec, I have a feeling this would be your answer.
所以越多——亚历克，我感觉这会是你的回答。
the more specific, the better the questions.
越具体，问题就越好。
Yes.
是的。
So what's the specific?
那具体是什么样的呢？
Right, so what happens is before we do an episode, we ask for episode specific questions, but for those letters that people are writing in.
对，所以情况是这样的：在我们制作一集节目之前，我们会征集针对特定剧集的问题，但对于大家写进来的那些信件。
That can be interesting.
那些可能会很有趣。
That thought episode specific.
那些不一定非要针对特定剧集。
Yeah, I think, I would say that, I mean, we have thousands, we have thousands of these letters and our co-producer Doug goes through them and finds them and our social media producer, Emily, she goes through them to find them.
对，我想，我会说，我的意思是，我们有成千上万封这样的信，我们的联合制作人道格（Doug）会过目并找出它们，我们的社交媒体制作人艾米丽（Emily）也会过目并找出它们。
And I think that we look for specific stories about your life, you know?
我觉得我们是在寻找关于你生活的具体故事，你知道吗？
We know you love the show, everyone loves the show.
我们知道你喜欢这部剧，每个人都喜欢这部剧。
How did it intersect with your life?
它如何与你的生活产生交集？
What does him mean to you?
《老爸老妈的浪漫史》对你意味着什么？
Yeah, that's a good point, I got it.
对，说得好，我明白了。
There's a big difference there.
这里面有很大的区别。
We like episode specific questions to do in our sort of general questions, general questions in the episode, about the episode, but the letters or voice notes you could leave us, just like, yeah, the personal touch.
我们喜欢针对剧集的问题来做我们那种常规问题，也就是每集中关于剧集本身的常规问题，但你们可以留给我们的信件或语音留言，就更有那种个人色彩。
We are so moved hearing those stories, right?
听到这些故事，我们太感动了，对吧？
Josh, that's like our favorite.
乔什，这可以说是我们的最爱。
Yeah.
对。
I mean, a lot of people, there's a lot of like romantic connections people make when they realize someone is a how I met your mother fan and then they immediately have something to kind of connect on, there's people who were going through really hard times and how I met your mother was like their one, their lone source of kind of comfort and laughter or during really hard life transitions and things, you know, parents getting sick or relationships ending or all kinds of things.
我是说，很多人，当他们发现某人也是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的粉丝时，他们会建立起很多浪漫的联系，然后他们立刻就有了某种共同语言；还有人曾经历过非常艰难的时期，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》就像是他们唯一的、孤独的舒适和欢笑来源，或者陪伴他们度过了非常艰难的人生转折期之类的事情，你知道的，比如父母生病、感情结束或者各种各样的事情。
So, you know, we love the big comedy moments of How I Make Mother, we talk about them, we laugh about them, but we also honor that in addition to how hilarious How I Make Mother is, it really breaks your heart, makes you cry every third or fourth episode.
所以，你知道，我们喜欢《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中那些宏大的喜剧时刻，我们谈论它们，我们为之开怀大笑，但我们也同样致敬这样一点：除了这部剧有多么爆笑之外，每隔三四集，它真的会让你心碎，让你落泪。
So, we also want to honor that that's kind of part of the emotional connection people have with the show, you know?
所以，我们也想向这一点致敬，因为这也是人们对这部剧的情感连接的一部分，你知道吗？
Yeah.
对。
That's our favorite part to hear about.
这是我们最喜欢听到的话题。
Yeah, Craig, do you think you and I are gonna be able to have dinner tomorrow night?
对了，克雷格，你觉得今晚你和我能一起吃晚饭吗？
We have a dinner schedule, I just wanna check.
我们排了晚餐日程，我只是想确认一下。
I was worried that I was waking up a little congested, and I know there's a young one in your home now, so I'm taking that for seriously.
我有点担心自己醒来时觉得有点鼻塞，而且我知道你家里现在有个小宝宝，所以我对此很严肃。
Can we clarify that that's a child of mine and not some weird thing that's going on?
我们能澄清一下那是我的孩子，而不是什么奇怪的事情吗？
By the way, yes, we have to clarify that.
顺便说一句，是的，我们必须澄清这一点。
We have to clarify that.
我们必须澄清这一点。
It's exactly the moment where we need to clarify that in American history.
在美利坚历史上，这正是我们需要澄清这一点的时刻。
the baby that you have created with your wife is in your house.
你和你的妻子所孕育的婴儿正待在你的家里。
And so I will update you with anything changes, but I'm feeling okay.
所以如果有任何变化我会向你汇报，但我觉得我感觉还可以。
I appreciate you trying to keep my house safe.
我很感激你试图确保我家里安全。
We just got through our first bout of sickness in the house.
我们才刚经历完家里的第一场感冒。
I know, you guys were out of that.
我知道，你们已经熬过去了。
No fun.
一点也不好玩。
That's why I would never forgive myself if I introduced a new cold interior.
这就是为什么如果我把一个新的感冒病毒带进屋里，我永远都不会原谅自己。
Did Jordana get it too eventually?
乔丹娜最后也中招了吗？
She did not.
她没有。
Just you, ah.
只有你，啊。
She did not, but me and the boy did.
她没有，但我跟这男孩中招了。
So, anyway, Alec, where are people tuning in from?
所以，总之，亚历克，大家都是从哪里收听的？
What are we feeling, who's saying hi?
我们感觉怎么样，都有谁在打招呼？
They're definitely coming in from around the world.
他们绝对是来自世界各地。
You caught me cold there, I don't have my list coming yet.
你刚才突然问我，我还没把名单调出来呢。
I don't know.
我不知道。
We are on a different app, so we're not seeing all the questions.
我们在另一个应用上，所以我们看不到所有问题。
Craig and I, Alec and Catherine are filtering them for us.
克雷格和我、亚历克和凯瑟琳正在帮我们筛选。
And we should say this, we did this at noon today, hoping we would reach some people in some different time zones.
我们应该说明一下，我们今天中午做了这个，希望能接触到不同时区的一些人。
The other couple of IG lives we've done have been at 8 p.m.
我们之前做过的其他几次IG直播都是在晚上8点。
Eastern Standard Time, New York Time.
美国东部时间，纽约时间。
Only European Insomniacs could tune into that.
只有欧洲的失眠症患者才能看那个。
So we got some very, very interesting questions.
所以我们收到了一些非常非常有趣的问题。
Right.
对。
All right.
好吧。
I can give you a love from Germany and watching from the Philippines and bonjour de la France.
我可以告诉你，有来自德国的爱，有来自菲律宾的观众，还有来自法国的问候。
And many people just testing my knowledge by texting flag emojis.
还有许多人发国旗表情符号来考验我的知识。
You're going to fail that.
你肯定会答不上来的。
And they pop up so tiny or squinting in a flag.
而且它们弹出来太小了，或者得眯着眼睛看国旗。
You gotta screenshot it, then blow it up and then, yeah.
你得截屏，然后放大，然后，对。
Okay, we have a couple of indias and Brazil and Romania and Georgia, don't know which one, but Georgia, Ecuador, Iowa, Italy, oh my goodness, they are coming in here.
好吧，有几个印度的、巴西的、罗马尼亚的、格鲁吉亚的（不知道是哪个，但确实是格鲁吉亚）、厄瓜多尔的、爱荷华州的、意大利的，哦天哪，他们源源不断地涌进来。
So, Iran, Utah, love to the people of Iran, yes, amazing.
还有，伊朗，犹他州，向伊朗人民致意，是的，太棒了。
Well, questions are pouring in, please folks, do send us your questions now, we actually have Josh and we actually have Craig right here to answer them for you.
好了，问题如潮水般涌来，各位请尽管给我们发问题吧，我们真的有乔什，也真的有克雷格在这里为你们解答。
Josh, several people are a little concerned with the fact that you now seem to be in a closet rather than in a living room and they're just simply asking, where is Josh?
乔什，好几个人有点担心，因为你现在看起来好像是在一个壁橱里，而不是在客厅里，他们只是简单地问，乔什在哪里？
Yeah.
对。
This is my wife's office.
这是我太太的办公室。
There's a like a kind of therapist chair here.
这里有一把类似于心理医生的椅子。
It's bigger.
它挺大的。
I think then is I'm not in a I'm very claustrophobic.
我觉得……我不在……我有严重的幽闭恐惧症。
I would not be in a do well in a closet.
我可待不住壁橱，也受不了那种环境。
So, I'm in my wife's office, but the house is a little full today.
所以，我在我太太的办公室，但家里今天有点挤。
There's a lot buzzing around.
到处都很吵闹。
So this was my only private space, but thank you for your concern.
所以这是我唯一的私人空间，不过谢谢大家的关心。
Reporting in New York City.
在纽约市进行报道。
And in New York City, that is a spacious office, by the way.
顺便说一句，在纽约市，那可算是一间很宽敞的办公室了。
Yeah.
对。
Whatever.
随便吧。
What did I saw some tweets that said, people in New York City be like, you want to come over tonight and sit in my other chair?
我看到有些推特上说，纽约市的人会说：“今晚你想过来坐在我的另一把椅子上吗？”
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, the How I Met Your Mother apartment, not as egregious as friends but still unrealistically big for you, probably.
对，《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的公寓，虽然不像《老友记》那么离谱，但对你来说可能还是大得不切实际。
Well you got it right with Lily's apartment when she had the high, the wall bed, or the vertical.
嗯，你猜得挺准，就像莉莉的公寓里有那个高架床，或者壁床。
Way more accurate.
精确得多。
That is way wildly more accurate.
那可真是离谱地精准得多。
You know a lot of people, I mean this is maybe like inside her showbiz, but the reason it's really hard to do honest New York apartments is because you have to fit a whole camera crew in there.
你知道很多人——我的意思是这可能有点像娱乐圈的内幕——之所以很难拍出真实的纽约公寓，是因为你得把整个摄影团队塞进去。
It's so hard to shoot.
太难拍摄了。
It's really hard to shoot.
拍这个真的很难。
Yeah, that's why we basically tried to make it smaller than friends.
对，这就是为什么我们基本上把它设计得比《老友记》里的小。
We were just like, we were just like, this is how to see balls.
我们当时就觉得，这就是怎么看球。
And friends has been yelled out about this for our entire adult lives.
而且《老友记》在我们整个成年生活中一直都在因为这个被吐槽。
Can we not, let's not be egregious.
我们能别这样吗，别太离谱了。
But also it wasn't friends downtown and you guys are up, we were up our west side.
但当时那不是市中心的老友记，你们在上面，我们在城西。
This was up our west.
这是在上城西区。
Yeah.
对。
So it was a little bit of a, it was easier to go smaller in that regard.
所以这有点，在这方面把布景做小一点容易多了。
And I think friends always said like it was like their aunt's apartment or so there was some like way they tried to speak to it.
而且我觉得《老友记》总是说，比如那是他们阿姨的公寓，所以总有什么方式来解释它。
But it was, you could, you could lend a plane in that part.
但那是，你可以在那个地方停一架飞机。
It was gigantic.
它太巨大了。
And Tana Marshall, we were like, let's not make it like, it can't be perfect.
而对于《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我们就想，别把它弄得，它不可能完美。
It has to be a little dark.
它必须稍微昏暗一点。
In season two, we actually brightened up the paint a little bit because we thought we made it too dark.
在第二季中，我们实际上把油漆调亮了一点，因为我们觉得第一季弄得太暗了。
In season one, at the end of season one, someone was like, maybe the network.
在第一季，第一季结束时，有人说，也许是电视台。
They're like, it's a little drab of that apartment.
他们说，那间公寓稍微有点沉闷。
But it's real.
但它是真实的。
And they're like, let's get more ratings.
然后他们说，让我们获得更高的收视率吧。
We didn't notice that the couch switches from season one to season two, but it's a direct pickup.
我们没有注意到第一季到第二季沙发换了，但这完全是无缝衔接的。
Yeah.
对。
So they like come in from like literally going downstairs and they come back and there's a new couch no one comments on it no one comments on it except the fans who now you know go episode episode quickly so they catch it they got a couch delivery in the brief four minutes well Marshall was crying on the stoop with that's the problem with someone brought in a new couch Marshall was actually he was actually crying because he missed the old couch well they put out on the Bermuda Triangle in front of the apartment which we we got to later and It disappears like that.
所以他们就像是从字面意思上走到楼下去然后回来，就换了新沙发，谁都没对此发表评论，除了现在你们知道一集接一集快速观看从而发现这一点的粉丝们，他们在短短四分钟内送到了一个新沙发，当时马歇尔正哭着靠在门廊前，这就是问题所在，有人搬来了一个新沙发，马歇尔其实是在，他其实是在哭，因为他怀念旧沙发，好吧，他们把它扔在了公寓前面的百慕大三角，我们后来讨论到了这个，然后它就那样消失了。
So it all really breaks.
所以这一切其实都说不通。
Yeah.
对。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小歌，在纽约市唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在欢迎回到节目。
All right.
好的。
We could shout out Turkey and Argentina and Netherlands and Albania and Mexico.
我们可以向土耳其、阿根廷、荷兰、阿尔巴尼亚和墨西哥打个招呼。
Amazing here.
这里太棒了。
Craig, here's one for you.
克雷g，这里有一个给你的。
How do you feel about the Late Show franchise ending?
你对《深夜秀》系列的结束有什么看法？
About the Late Show franchise about, oh my God, I feel terrible about it.
关于《深夜秀》系列的结束，哦天哪，我对此感觉糟糕透了。
Tell us a little about why this question was directed at it.
给我们讲讲为什么这个问题是针对它的。
Yeah, okay, let me, yes.
好吧，好吧，让我想想，是的。
That's why it took me a second because it was like, what's my right?
这就是为什么我愣了一下，因为我想，我的权利是什么？
I am Carter Bayes and I used to write for Late Show with David Letterman, the host before Stephen Colbert, who Carter and I grew up in the 80s, idolizing Dave.
我是卡特·贝斯，我曾为大卫·莱特曼主持的《深夜秀》写过剧本，他是史蒂芬·科尔伯特之前的主持人，卡特和我是在80年代崇拜大卫长大的。
We had a really crazy late night show on at 1230 on NBC.
我们在NBC12点半档有一个非常疯狂的深夜节目。
That was like a mad scientist comedy lab.
那就像是一个疯狂科学家的喜剧实验室。
And then it moved to, while we were in college, he moved to more, led the 1130 slot, a bigger audience, and CBS, and the show became a little less insane, but still great, Dave's a legend.
然后，在我们上大学的时候，它搬到了11点半的时段，拥有更大的观众群，在CBS播出了，节目变得没有那么疯狂了，但依然很棒，大卫是个传奇。
We were 22, and we got hired to write for Dave Letterman.
我们当时22岁，被雇用为大卫·莱特曼写剧本。
It was amazing.
太棒了。
And so we took a lot of pride.
所以我们感到非常自豪。
We were there four and a half years.
我们在那里待了四年半。
It launched our entire career, changed our life completely.
它开启了我们的整个职业生涯，彻底改变了我们的生活。
Thank you, Dave, and everybody that worked there.
谢谢你，大卫，还有在那里工作的所有人。
And then Dave passed it off to Stephen Colbert, and the idea that that franchise is ending, perhaps with a bunch of asterisks attached to it that have to do with free speech and things we won't get super political about on our IG live, it's sad to me.
后来大卫把节目交给了史蒂芬·科尔伯特，一想到这个系列节目就要结束了，可能还带有一堆与言论自由以及我们不会在IG直播中过分深入探讨的政治话题相关的星号，我就觉得很伤心。
Why is that show going away?
为什么这个节目要消失？
What are the forces behind that?
背后的力量是什么？
Comedy needs to survive.
喜剧需要生存。
We need a climate where people can tell the truth through comedy, that's what comedy is there for, that's why we have free speech.
我们需要一个能让人通过喜剧说真话的环境，喜剧存在的意义就在于此，这也是我们拥有言论自由的原因。
If there's any part of that show going off the air that's related to these issues, which a lot of people think is the case that that bums me out even more than just it bums me out.
如果那个节目的停播有任何一部分与这些问题相关——很多人都觉得确实如此——那比起节目本身停播，这件事更让我感到难过。
The idea of the institution of the late, the late show that I worked for going away, you walk past that spot in Midtown.
一想到我曾工作过的那个深夜秀机构将不复存在，你走过中城的那段路……
I spent, Carter and I spent almost five years exactly in that spot on 53rd and Broadway.
我和卡特在53街和百老汇交界的那地方，差不多整整待了五年。
The big marquee, the writer's office is up above it.
那个巨大的遮阳篷，编剧办公室就在它上方。
It's an institution.
这是一个机构。
There's something cool about almost like, it's like your college going out of business.
这种感觉有点酷，就像……就像你的母校倒闭了一样。
That's what this feels like.
这感觉就是这样。
It feels like your university.
感觉就像你的大学。
going to go to the spot where your college campus wasn't just gone.
你走到那个地方，结果发现你的大学校园竟然凭空消失了。
And that was our kind of our comedy grad school.
那是我们喜剧界的“研究生院”。
And I every time I walk by the Colbert League show, I smile because I remember I'm happy there's still that show, a version of that show happening there.
每次我走过史蒂芬·科拜尔的节目现场，我都会微笑，因为我记得、我也很高兴那里依然有那个节目，有那个节目的某个版本在继续。
And yeah, I feel sad.
是的，我感到难伤心。
I feel sad about it going away.
为它的消逝感到伤心。
And also without you guys having written for David Letterman, there's no how I may or mother.
而且，如果没有你们为大卫·莱特曼写过剧本，就不会有《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
I mean, it's a direct line from Wesleyan to Letterman to stage 22 on the Fox lot and how I met your mother a straight line there's no world how I met your mother would have happened without us being in that spot for four and a half years around the block from McGee's the how I met your mother bar where the bartender hopefully will now know we have a podcast yeah if you're just joining us closer Craig and I host a podcast we're re-watching how I met your mother from the start please join us it's called how we made your mother William, we call it, and you can just go to howwemadeyourmother.com and it'll direct you to all sorts of options for listening to the podcast on however you like to listen to podcasts.
我的意思是，从卫斯理大学到莱特曼，再到福克斯片场的22号摄影棚以及《老爸老妈浪漫史》，这是一条直线，一条直通到底的线；如果我们没有在莱特曼节目组附近那个地方待上四年半，就在麦吉酒吧（《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的那个酒吧，酒保现在希望已经知道我们有个播客了）的街角，那就绝不可能有《老爸老妈浪漫史》的世界。对，如果你刚加入我们，克雷格和我主持了一个播客，我们正在从头重温《老爸老妈浪漫史》，请加入我们，它叫“我们是如何创造你母亲的”，威廉，我们这么叫它，你可以直接访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，它会引导你通过你喜欢的方式收听这个播客的各种选项。
Patrick Felton W asks a very timely question, which is, I realize now by the time the rest of the world hears this Instagram live, this Instagram live where you are all asking us questions now will appear as a podcast in a couple of months, but he'd like to know about the proposal that started out just this week's episode and says, have you had a message of how the proposal worked out on the last episode of Quimium, and all I can announce is that for those listening live, yes, and stay tuned in just a couple of episodes where you're going to hear the outcome of that wedding proposal.
帕特里克·费尔顿·W 问了一个非常应景的问题，我意识到，等世界其他地方听到这个Instagram直播时——你们现在正在直播中向我们提问的这个Instagram直播——会在几个月后作为播客发布，但他想知道这周节目刚开始时的那个求婚，并问：“你们有没有收到关于上集节目中求婚结果的消息？”我能宣布的是，对于正在收听直播的人来说：是的，请继续关注接下来的几期节目，你们就会听到那个求婚的结局。
We just got some news this very morning with with some photos attached to it.
就在今天早上，我们刚刚收到了一些消息，还附带了一些照片。
So that's good.
所以这很好。
I've been on a TV show, how I met your mother, where there was an actual proposal.
我曾参演过一部电视剧《老爸老妈浪漫史》，里面确实有一场求婚戏。
Oh yeah, that's right.
哦对，没错。
I've had three, maybe four proposals at music venues where I've been playing shows.
在我演出过的音乐场所里，有过三四次求婚。
Wait, that you've been proposed to or someone else?
等等，是向你求婚还是别人？
I've gotten a couple of those.
我有过几次这样的经历。
But no, people, you know, ask, you know, they're gonna propose at the show.
但不是，人们，你知道的，会问，他们会在演出时求婚。
I brought one couple up on stage.
我曾把一对情侣请上舞台。
Actually in Buenos Aires, No, not in Buenos Aires, sorry.
其实是在布宜诺斯艾利斯——不，不是在布宜诺斯艾利斯，抱歉。
In Sao Paulo, when I was playing with Ben Lee, we had a proposal on stage.
在圣保罗，我和本·李一起演出时，我们在台上经历了一场求婚。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
And then now in the podcast, like in this podcast.
然后现在在播客里，就像在这个播客里一样。
So, yeah.
所以，是的。
So if you stick with me, folks, if you're looking to partner off, I would clearly.
所以如果你们跟着我，各位，如果你们想找伴侣，我绝对……
That's in this week's episode, right?
那是这周的节目对吧？
The one that's out right now, the Monday Night Football episode, right?
就是现在刚播出的那一集，周一橄榄球那一集，对吧？
That episode begins with a fan message that ends with a proposal.
那一集的开场是一个粉丝留言，最后以求婚结束。
And yes, so stay tuned, tune in, and you will hear the answer to everything about that.
是的，所以请继续关注，收听节目，你们就会听到关于这一切的答案。
We were blown away.
我们惊呆了。
And Alec is a very, Alec, you're very clever.
亚历克，你真的很聪明。
You like springing things on Josh.
你喜欢给乔伊搞突袭。
You don't always tell us about what do you have up your sleeve when we're recording the podcast.
我们在录制播客时，你并不总是告诉我们你葫芦里卖的什么药。
You blew our minds with that.
你那招让我们大开眼界。
So yeah, tune in and we won't get up to it.
所以，是的，收听节目吧，我们就不剧透了。
We often haven't heard the audio message, nor have we, I mean, you sometimes send this C-block letter over to us, but most of the time we're reading it cold, which actually I think really helps us respond pretty authentically in the moment.
我们通常没有听过语音留言，也没有……我的意思是，你有时会把C区块的信件发给我们，但大多数时候我们都是现场盲读，其实我觉得这真的有助于我们在当时做出非常真实的反应。
You know, yeah.
你知道的，是的。
Right.
没错。
None of that has anything to do with the fact that I haven't prepared until about one hour before the show starts.
这些都跟我直到节目开始前大约一个小时才开始准备没有任何关系。
I thought I was letting you off the hook, man.
我还以为我在帮你解围呢，老兄。
I was kidding.
我开玩笑呢。
I'll edit this part out.
我会把这部分剪掉的。
You do it from yourself under the bus.
你自己把自己给卖了。
You're the guy that can edit that out.
你才是那个能把这剪掉的人。
You're the guy.
你就是那个人。
You can make yourself yourself.
你可以让自己……
No editing.
不剪。
A couple of just lovely notes here that we're getting here.
这里有一些我们收到的非常可爱的留言。
Anna.gi.
Anna.gi。
I says, you maybe love your character, Josh so much.
I 说，你让我也太爱乔伊这个角色了，
I named my baby after him.
我用他的名字给我的宝宝取了名。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Evelyn.
伊芙琳。
Ahh.
啊。
Dr. Axe.
阿克斯医生。
Baby Dr. Axe.
小阿克斯医生。
My baby Dr. Axe.
我的小阿克斯医生。
Here's one where, I mean, you guys, obviously, over the decades now, I've heard so many of these kinds of comments.
这里有一个，我的意思是，你们几个，显然几十年来，已经听过很多这种评论了。
But I know that on the show, often you'll slow down and you'll go, hey, you know, when we sat down to do this show, did we ever imagine?
但我知道在节目中，你们经常会慢下来然后说：“嘿，你知道，当我们坐下来做这个节目时，我们曾经想象过吗？”
So just real basic.
所以非常基础。
It, Melita says, we raised our kids and taught them life lessons from the show.
梅莉塔说，我们抚养孩子，并从节目中教给他们生活的教训。
I mean, was that ever something, Craig?
我的意思是，克雷格，这曾是你想过的事吗？
Your card is sitting around, drumming up your pilot here.
你和卡特坐在一起，在这里捣鼓你们的试播集。
Could you imagine that this is, that it, Melita, two decades later, are gonna raise their kids and teach them life off to the shit that you saw.
你能想象到，梅莉塔在二十年后会用你们写出的那些东西来抚养他们的孩子并教导他们生活吗？
I'm still dealing with how old that makes us.
我还在消化这把我们衬托得有多老这件事。
I'm not over with us being super old part.
我们已经超级老了这一事实，我还没缓过来。
When that wave of nausea passes, I'll be able to appreciate this more.
等那阵反胃感过去后，我才能更好地体会这一点。
But it's like you and Carter are like the new Dr. Spock.
但这就好像你和卡特成了新一代的斯巴克医生。
He's teaching a generation how to parent their children.
他在教导一代人如何抚养孩子。
Yes, yes, that's exactly what we thought we were up to when we were drinking at McGee's around the corner from Letterman in 1999.
对，对，这正是我们在1999年莱特曼拐角处的麦吉酒吧喝酒时，以为自己在做的事。
And we're like, someday kids will be taught by whatever bullshit we're coming up with.
当时我们想：“总有一天，孩子们会被我们胡思乱想出来的狗屁东西教育。”
Yeah, and no, it's stunning, it's stunning.
对，不，这太惊人了，太惊人了。
Well, also Craig, you know, we talked, especially in first season about, that you guys were 29 when you started writing this show, right?
不过话说回来，克雷格，你知道的，我们讨论过，特别是在第一季的时候，你们写这个剧的时候才29岁，对吧？
29 to 38.
29到38岁。
But you were writing this older man's voice who was 20, 25 years older than you.
但你们写的是一个比你们大20到25岁的老年男性的声音。
But you had to imagine a kind of wiser, older version of yourself to write that part, right?
但为了写好那个角色，你们不得不想象一个更明智、更年长的自己，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
So I remember you said, and maybe Carter said this when he was on, but you guys were kind of trying to write a comforting voice for yourself, like imagining what would you want to hear your older self say about these years?
所以我记得你说过，也许卡特上节目时也说过，你们当时其实是在为自己写一个能带来安慰的声音，就像想象一下，关于这些岁月，你希望年长后的自己对你说些什么？
Yeah.
是的。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
That 100%.
100%是。
playing wisdom.
假装充满智慧。
And we were like, it's fake until you make it.
我们当时的想法就是：装到你把它变成真的为止。
How do I hope I'll look at this time?
我希望我将如何看待这段时光？
How does younger me hope older me will frame this and make sense of this?
年轻的我希望年老的我如何去诠释和理解这段经历？
And again, I know I've said this before, but like we missed New York so much.
再次声明，我知道这话我以前说过，但我们太想念纽约了。
We did our 20s in New York, writing for Dave Letterman.
我们的20多岁是在纽约度过的，为戴夫·莱特曼写稿。
We moved to LA, did how much her mother, and we missed New York.
我们搬到了洛杉矶，拍了老爸老妈浪漫史，而我们想念纽约。
The second the planes wheels set down in Los Angeles, I'll do respect to Los Angeles, we missed New York terribly.
飞机轮子一在洛杉矶着陆——我对洛杉矶并无不敬——我们就无比想念纽约。
9-11 had happened not that long before our move.
我们搬家前不久才发生了911事件。
And I feel like we missed a New York that was like before that horrible tragedy.
我觉得我们怀念的是那个可怕悲剧发生之前的纽约。
And like something about that sequence of events and these huge leaps we were taking in life and a leap away from a really hard time for New York City, it all colored how we wanted to look back.
这种事件的先后顺序，我们在生活中迈出的巨大步伐，以及对纽约市那段艰难时期的一次跨越，这一切都给我们的回忆涂上了色彩。
We began looking back at a very young age because it felt like a chapter had ended at that moment.
我们很早就开始回顾过去，因为感觉那一刻就像是一个章节的结束。
we moved in 2002 to Los Angeles, like six months after 9-11.
我们是在2002年搬到洛杉矶的，大约在911事件六个月后。
And I think that really, there's something about that moment in time that informed the idea of how will we look back from the future at now.
我想，那段时光确实对我们的观念产生了影响：未来我们该如何回首现在。
And I think that injected something into a mid-term other that might not have been there otherwise.
我想这给老爸老妈浪漫史注入了一些原本可能不会有的东西。
We have M.
我们有M。
Beth, G78 just wants us to know that her sister's apartment in Queens is 500 square feet.
Beth，G78只是想让我们知道她在皇后区的姐姐的公寓有500平方英尺。
There's a lot smaller than that one, too.
比那个还要小得多呢。
Benny, I believe it's just thank you for your music, Josh.
Benny，我想这只是谢谢你的音乐，乔希。
It really means so much more to people than you think and greetings from Germany.
它对人们的意义真的比你想象的要重大得多，来自德国的问候。
Oh, that's so kind of you.
哦，你太好了。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, I feel like, Josh, first of all, Josh does the theme song of this podcast.
对，我觉得，乔希，首先，乔希做了这个播客的主题曲。
That's Josh's song, NYC.
那是乔希的歌，NYC。
And yeah, for anybody that's like new to the podcast and maybe new to the idea that Josh does music, go look him up on Apple Music.
是的，对于任何刚接触这个播客、可能刚知道乔希会做音乐的人来说，去Apple Music上搜搜他吧。
They'll look him up on Spotify.
去Spotify上搜搜他。
It's just gem after gem after gem, brilliant melodies, brilliant lyrics.
简直是一首接一首的宝藏，绝妙的旋律，绝妙的歌词。
And this guy didn't pick up a guitar to how much the mother ended.
而且这家伙直到老爸老妈浪漫史结束才拿起吉他。
It's unbelievable what you did in that span of time to arrive at the place where you're the songwriter and singer that you are.
你在那么短的时间里取得这样的成就，成长为你现在这样的词曲作者和歌手，这真是不可思议。
It's really great.
真的很棒。
I'm not just saying that.
我可不是随便说说。
Everybody needs to go look that up right now, if you have it.
如果你们还没听过，大家现在都去搜一下。
That's so kind of you, Craig.
克雷格，你太好了。
I would also like to make a pitch for doing something that you think you're too old to do that you always have the sense that you want to do.
我也想借此机会呼吁大家去尝试一些你觉得自己年龄太大而不该做、但内心一直想做的事情。
And, you know, I always, you know, I was an obsessive music fan along with Carter and Craig.
而且，你知道的，我一直，你知道的，我和卡特还有克雷格一样，是个痴迷的音乐迷。
I recommended a lot of songs and bands that got onto the show.
我推荐了很多最终进入节目的歌曲和乐队。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
And, but I always, whenever I would watch music, it was almost like I loved it so much that I felt like I could do it.
而且，但是每当我看音乐时，我几乎是太喜欢了，以至于我觉得自己也能做到。
And then I started writing songs with my friend, Ben Lee.
然后我开始和我的朋友本·李一起写歌。
And now, and I started playing guitar basically at 40, 41 maybe.
现在，我大概在40岁、41岁左右开始弹吉他。
And it's just been such a joy in my life to pick it up later.
能在晚些时候重新拾起它，是我人生中的一大快乐。
And I think I had this idea that you had to start it when you were 12, 15, have the band and your parents garage.
我想我以前有这种观念，觉得你必须在12岁、15岁时就开始，在父母的车库里组乐队。
And I just did it in a different way.
而我是用一种不同的方式做到的。
And it's just been a real source of joy in my life.
这确实成了我生命中快乐的源泉。
So thank you for that, Craig.
所以谢谢你，克雷格。
Oh, I mean, you're legitimately really good at it.
噢，我是说，你真的很有天赋。
It's really great that you picked this extra artistic tool up and you didn't decide for no reason, right?
你掌握了这门额外的艺术工具，而且你并不是无缘无故才决定的，对吧？
We all talk ourselves out of shit.
我们总是自我设限打退堂鼓。
I'm too old to do this.
我太老了，做不了这个。
No, you're great at it.
不，你做得很棒。
You picked it up at 40 and you're amazing.
你40岁才开始学，现在太厉害了。
I'm so good at it that Jenna Fisher retroactively thought I was playing guitar in 2006, when she did the reading at my house.
我厉害到珍娜·费舍甚至追溯认为我在2006年她在我家读剧本时就在弹吉他了。
But I was not.
但我当时并没有。
I go backwards in time.
我能时光倒流。
Little shout out to Ben Lee.
向本·李致敬。
I don't know if I've ever even told you this, Josh.
我不知道我是不是甚至跟你说过这个，乔希。
Stop me if I have, or don't, because we'll just talk and this will be content for Alec to monetize later.
如果我说过就阻止我，或者别阻止，因为我们随便聊聊，这就能成为以后亚历克斯变现的内容。
But, Ben Lee, at the end of season one of How Much Mother, the show is a baby show.
但是，本·李，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季结束时，这节目当时还很新。
I think we were launching a season two, somewhere in between, because I remember the office we were in when we got this phone call.
我想我们当时正准备推出第二季，就在那个间隙，因为我记得我们接到这个电话时所在的办公室。
It was the season, we moved into, we must have been launching season two, the phone rings, and it's our assistant, and they go, it's Ben Lee calling from Australia.
那是我们要搬进……我们当时肯定是在准备推出第二季，电话响了，是我们助理，他们说，本·李从澳大利亚打来的。
We go, what?
我们说，什么？
We don't know, Ben Lee.
我们不认识本·李。
He's great.
他很棒。
We're fans of him.
我们是他的粉丝。
And he was cool, and we didn't know him.
他很酷，而我们不认识他。
And they were like, are you sure Ben Lee is calling for us?
他们就说，你们确定本·李是打给我们的吗？
Is there some other extension here on the Fox lot?
福克斯片场是不是还有别的分机号？
He might rather talk to than us.
他可能更想跟别人说话而不是我们？
Like, no, he's calling for you.
结果是，不，他是打给你们的。
And we got on the phone and he just goes, I just wanted to tell you how much mother is kind of hitting right now in Australia and we're loving it.
我们接起电话，他就说，我只是想告诉你们，老爸老妈浪漫史现在在澳大利亚正火呢，我们都很喜欢。
I'm loving this show so much.
我太喜欢这个节目了。
It really speaks to me.
它真的很触动我。
The tone of it, the heart of it, the music of it.
它的基调，它的内核，它的音乐。
He didn't know you yet.
他还不太认识你。
I don't think Josh.
我觉得乔希还不是。
This is 20 years ago, this story.
这个故事是20岁前的事了。
Well, I mean, he just reached out.
嗯，我是说，他只是主动联系了我们。
And I remember it's slightly different.
我记得情况稍微有点不同。
Did you guys try to get a song of his and his label, I think he was maybe with Warner Brothers at the time, like his label like priced him out.
是不是你们想用他的一首歌，而他的唱片公司——我想他当时可能签约了华纳兄弟——把价格抬得太高了？
Like you guys couldn't afford the song.
就好像你们买不起这首歌。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I don't remember that.
我不记得这个了。
And I'll check with Ben.
我去跟本核实一下。
But I thought- I think he cold called us.
但我以为——我觉得他是冷不丁给我们打电话。
I don't think he cold called you to say I'm sorry they didn't give you that song if they had asked me.
我觉得他打冷电可不是为了说“如果他们问我的话，我很遗憾他们没把那首歌给你”。
Oh maybe.
哦，也许吧。
I would have told them to give it to you.
我会告诉他们把歌给你们的。
And then you guys invited him to set, right?
然后你们邀请他去片场了，对吧？
When he was back in L.S.
当他回洛杉矶的时候。
Yes, yes, yes.
对，对，对。
You come to set and like just see how we made the show.
你来到片场，看看我们是怎么制作这个节目的。
Yeah.
对。
And that's when I met him.
那就是我认识他的时候。
And that's the whole reason I'm a songwriter just because I became friends with Ben and we started writing songs together.
而这就是我成为词曲作者的全部原因，只因为我跟本成了朋友，我们开始一起写歌。
Isn't that crazy?
这不是很疯狂吗？
So he cold calls because he just, how much mother spoke to him in some way?
所以他主动打电话来，只是因为老爸老妈浪漫史在某种程度上触动了他？
And somehow that outcome leads to you two in Brazil and someone's proposing in Brazil because Ben Lee cold called our office at the first season too.
而不知何故，这个结果导致了你们两个在巴西，有人在巴西求婚，就因为本·李在第二季刚开始时给我们办公室打了个冷电？
That's fucking crazy, right?
这他妈太疯狂了，对吧？
I know.
我知道。
I'm so glad I ate so many gummies right before we started this because this is hitting me so.
我很高兴在开始前吃了那么多软糖，因为这药劲太大了。
You always wanted to hit it at the 26 minute mark of the Instagram live.
你总是想在Instagram直播的第26分钟让它起效。
It's just right when you want to be.
正好是你希望它起效的时候。
Yeah.
对。
J.D.
J.D. J.D.
Shaiman is just shouting us all out here.
谢曼在这里向大家大声打招呼呢。
He wants to say also look up the salads while you're looking up.
他还想说，你们在搜索的时候顺便也看看那些沙拉。
That's right.
没错。
And Radder and Lee.
还有雷德和李。
He also says, Alec, thank you for steering the quimium ship.
他还说，亚历克，谢谢你掌舵 quimium 这艘船。
You're welcome.
不客气。
And I'll also say, by the way, just sort of side note to say this publicly as they say, that I remember very clearly when I was rehearsing, I was directing this one woman opera and I was in my mother's apartment and the woman who was the singer was sitting on a couch and my phone was in front of her and she rings and she goes, Josh Radner is calling you and I guess she didn't know that there was already connection.
顺便我也说一下，公开说一下，就像他们常说的那样，我清楚地记得当我还在排练的时候，我在导演一部独陀歌剧，当时我在我妈妈的公寓里，那个女歌手正坐在沙发上，我的手机就在她面前，然后电话响了，她说，乔什·雷德纳在给你打电话，我想她当时可能不知道电话其实已经接通了。
I was like, oh, that's even, no, Josh, we were friends.
我就想，哦，这甚至，不，乔什，我们是朋友。
That was a rarity.
这可真少见。
like that's not a big deal let it go to voicemail no but I I scurried over picked it up and very quickly you pitched doing this and asked me to come on board and to this day I am forever grateful for well I called I mean this is the this is the quickest podcast origin story in the world Jordan said I want to watch your show that I've never seen that was a decade of your life I called Craig should we do a podcast Craig said yeah of course let's call Alec we literally just called you yeah we added you into the call and you said yes and then oh wow we're doing it I didn't know that that was it was all on one call it was all launched on one call every every project you yeah think about happen as effortless amen amen yeah well thank you it's not the TV development process.
就像这没什么大不了的，让它进语音信箱吧。不，但我还是小跑过去接起电话，你非常快地向我推销了这个想法，邀请我加入，直到今天我依然无比感激——我当时打了电话，我是说，这是世界上节奏最快的播客起源故事，乔丹说我想看你的节目，而我从来没看过，那是你人生中的十年，我打电话给克雷格，我们该做个播客吗，克雷格说，好啊，当然，我们给亚历克打电话吧，我们真的就给你打了电话，是的，我们把你拉进了通话中，你说好，然后，哦，哇，我们这就开始做了，我当时不知道原来就在一个电话里搞定，一切都在一个电话里促成了，你觉得会发生的每个项目都这么毫不费力，阿门，阿门，好吧，谢谢，这可不是电视剧的开发过程。
This is the brilliant thing about podcasts.
这就是播客的妙处所在。
You just fucking do it.
你们他妈的直接就做了。
I mean, you know, I don't know how much you'll have to say about this, but JIC 2012 probably speaks for many who asked, what do you guys think of Jason and Kobe getting together on shrinking?
我是说，我知道你对这件事可能没太多要说的，但 JIC 2012 可能说出了许多人的心声，他们问，你们觉得杰森和科比在《诚实诊疗层》里合作感觉怎么样？
What a wild connection that is.
这是一种多么奇妙的联系啊。
So Kobe is on shrinking and Jason's daughter, Jason's character's daughter is trying to get into Wesleyan on shrinking.
所以科比出演了《诚实诊疗层》，而在剧中杰森的女儿，也就是杰森角色的女儿正试图考入卫斯理大学。
It's like, yes, the computer The theater simulation that runs life is running out of ideas and just recycling ingredients now.
这就好像，没错，运行现实的那个电脑剧场模拟程序已经江郎才尽，现在只能回收旧素材了。
No, it's cool.
不，这很酷。
It's very cool.
非常酷。
It's very cool to see them together.
看到他们在一起非常酷。
And it just feels like something comforting to my videos.
这感觉就像对我的老剧的一种抚慰。
What I was thinking about when I kept seeing previews for it, I was like in the kind of constellation, so you have these five characters and how I met your mother.
我一直看到它的宣传片时就在想，在那种星系般的角色关系中，比如《老爸老妈浪漫史》里有这五个角色。
So like me and Barney had a ton of stuff.
我和巴尼有很多对手戏。
Me and Marshall had a ton of stuff.
我和马歇尔有很多对手戏。
Me and Lily had a ton of stuff.
我和莉莉有很多对手戏。
Lily and Robin had a ton of stuff.
莉莉和罗宾有很多对手戏。
Lily and Barney had a ton of stuff.
莉莉和巴尼有很多对手戏。
Marshall and Barney had a ton of stuff.
马歇尔和巴尼有很多对手戏。
The two characters I would say that had the kind of least.
要说戏份最少的两个角色。
Definitely.
绝对是。
Were Marshall and Robin.
就是马歇尔和罗宾。
Yeah, we missed a bet there.
对，我们在那上面错失良机了。
Maybe we should have done more with them.
也许我们应该在他们身上多做点文章。
They're great together.
他们在一起很棒。
But it's cool that they're now getting to work together in that way.
但现在他们能以那种方式再次合作，真的很酷。
Not that they weren't set every day in the booth together at the same time.
并不是说他们以前不是每天都在录音室里同时待着。
But there weren't road trip movies of the two of them too much.
只不过没有太多关于他们俩的公路电影。
There was one where they bonded over this Minnesota bar and they had a Canadian bar and a Minnesotan bar and feeling displacement.
有一集是他们通过一个明尼苏达酒吧产生共鸣，一个加拿大酒吧和一个明尼苏达酒吧，还有那种背井离乡的感觉。
Did they also have like they were impervious to the cold together?
他们是不是还有那种一起对寒冷免疫的设定？
They were impervious to the cold.
他们对寒冷免疫。
Yeah, we found those little overlaps, but I do feel like we could have done more there.
对，我们找到了那些微小的交集，但我确实觉得我们本可以做更多。
So maybe the universe is evening it out now in some way.
所以也许宇宙现在正在某种程度上弥补这一点。
So thank you, Jason Segal, for doing that.
所以谢谢杰森·席格尔做这件事。
Correcting that error on our part.
纠正了我们当年的那个失误。
They're coming in here.
他们进来了。
Here's one.
这里有一个。
Are there, I mean, obviously our fans, your fans use, there are so many, so many lines, so many quotes that people use in their daily life.
有没有，我是说，很明显我们的粉丝，你们的粉丝会用，有那么多，那么多的台词，那么多人们在日常生活中使用的名言。
They tattoo them, they use them in their wedding proposals, and are there any quirks or callback jokes or lines that you find yourself using in real life?
他们把它纹在身上，在求婚时使用，有没有什么怪癖、呼应笑话或台词是你发现自己在现实生活中也会用的？
I mean, they must come up, but are you affected by him, him lines in your daily lives as the fans are?
我是说，这些肯定会出现，但你们会像粉丝那样在日常生活中受到《老爸老妈浪漫史》台词的影响吗？
I will say the major general runner is like impossible.
我要说的是那个萨长将军的歌词简直是不可能的任务。
Once you have that in your head, once it's in, you know?
一旦那首歌印在你脑海里，一旦进去了，你知道的。
You cannot erase that one, like you can't eternal sunshine that out of your head.
你无法抹去那个记忆，就像你无法用《美丽心灵的永恒阳光》把它从脑海里删掉一样。
Yeah, we talked about this on the show, that I got a letter from a couple that were huge, how I met your mother, friends, and they were having a baby, and she was at the end of something like a 28, 36-hour labor.
对，我们在节目里聊过这个，我收到过一对夫妻的信，他们是《老爸老妈浪漫史》和《老友记》的超级粉丝，当时他们正在生孩子，她经历了差不多28到36个小时的产程。
And the OBGYN was delivering her baby.
当时妇产科医生正在给她接生。
It was literally like, the baby's like almost, and she said, the OBGYN said, you know, push, you're having a major contraction, and she turned her husband, and she became the salute.
简直就像是，宝宝马上就要出来了，医生说，你知道的，用力，你正在经历一次大宫缩，结果她转向她丈夫，然后她做了一个敬礼的动作。
Right as her baby was being born.
就在她孩子出生的一瞬间。
We talked about this first season.
我们在第一季就聊过这个。
Do you not remember this?
你难道不记得了吗？
You know you did, but it's blow my mind all over again.
你知道你记得，但它再次把我震惊到了。
Like that kind of thing is so funny.
这种事情真的太搞笑了。
Like when we hear things like that, we're just like, that's an unbelievable thing.
每当我们听到这样的事情，我们就会觉得，这真的是一件难以置信的事。
And also like that kid, that's part of his birth story forever and ever and ever.
而且这孩子，这也成了他出生故事的一部分，永远永远都是。
And again, to trace, I think our theme of this particular episode slash IG Live, whatever we're doing here, is the butterfly flaps its wings and then someone makes a major salute when a baby's being born.
再说一次，回溯一下，我认为我们这期特别节目兼IG直播的主题——不管我们在这儿搞什么鬼——就是蝴蝶扇动了翅膀，然后当孩子出生时，有人庄严地敬了个礼。
Like the chaos theory is like that is the theme of this episode of good cast.
就像混沌理论一样，这就是这期播客的主题。
Well, it also speaks to the theme that, do you know how like I accepted an invitation very casually in 2022 to join my friend Jacob out of thing?
嗯，这也契合了这样一个主题：你知道我是怎么在2022年非常随性地接受了我朋友雅各布的邀请去参加一个活动的吗？
And it's where I met my wife.
也就是我在那儿遇到了我太太。
Yeah.
对。
But like the casualness with which I said yes to the invitation is I always look back on it It's like I didn't be like this is going to be a very momentous weekend in my life like and and yeah And in some ways I think like cuz we talk a lot about the like life philosophy on the show because the show itself is packed With life philosophies, but it's like this kind of idea.
但我答应这个邀请时是多么的随意啊，我回想起来总是觉得，当时我并没有觉得“这将是我人生中非常重大的一个周末”，而且，而且，是的，在某种程度上我觉得，因为我们在节目里经常探讨人生哲学，因为节目本身就充满了各种人生哲学，但它就是这种概念。
Yeah, okay There's there's big struggles and setbacks and failures that actually get you maybe where you need to be.
对，好吧，会有重大的挣扎、挫折和失败，它们实际上可能会把你带到你该去的地方。
But at the same time, a lot of life is just an accumulation of pretty casual moments that end up being very consequential.
但与此同时，生活中的很大一部分，只是一系列相当随意的时刻的积累，而这些时刻最终却产生了深远的影响。
Only in retrospect.
只有在回首往事时才明白。
只有在回首往事时。
Only in consequential, yeah, yeah.
只有在产生影响之后，对，对。
Alec Lev is the originator of the major general colonel of truth salute.
亚历克·莱夫是少将上校级真理敬礼的始祖。
And he and his friends did that in high school, right?
他和他的朋友们在高中时就这样做了，对吧？
Maybe even earlier in that, Alec.
亚历克，说不定在那个之前就开始了。
And then I, you met me in college.
然后我，你在大学时遇到了我。
I started doing it.
我开始这样做了。
Like Josh said, once it's in you, that's it.
正如乔希所说，一旦它进入了你的体内，那就这样了。
It's like a vaccine.
这就像打疫苗一样。
It's just in your bloodstream forever.
它就永远在你的血液里了。
It's been ejected in you.
它已经被注入了你的体内。
And Craig, also one of the great comedy thieves of our life, our time.
还有克雷格，也是我们生活、我们这个时代最伟大的喜剧小偷之一。
I have no problem stealing other people's material.
我毫不介意偷用别人的素材。
I've never seen it.
我从没见过。
Be careful.
小心点。
You say a funny thing around Craig.
你在克雷格身边说个笑话。
It's gonna end up in a book for all of these stuff.
最后肯定会出现在他的书里或者别的地方。
I definitely did that to Alec.
我确实对亚历克这么做过。
I don't remember if I asked you permission.
我不记得我有没有征得你的同意。
Did I, Alec?
我有吗，亚历克？
I'm not.
我没有。
I think that that one I did.
我觉得那次我是征求了的。
A lot of times I didn't.
很多时候我都没有。
No, I think you knew that I was.
不，我想你当时知道我会。
I still miss from our lives.
我依然怀念的生活中的一部分。
No, I think you knew that I would be overjoyed by the life.
不，我想你当时知道我会为此欣喜若狂。
I think I knew you would be overjoyed by the life.
我想我知道你会为此欣喜若狂。
Did Carter also know it?
卡特也知道吗？
Did Carter do it?
卡特也这么做了吗？
Yeah, I think we had Carter doing it too, because we all went to college together.
对，我想我们让卡特也这么做了，因为我们都是一起上大学的。
How Carter, Alec, and I all went to Wesley and bring Wesley in back full circle.
卡特、亚历克和我如何去韦斯利，并让韦斯利重新回到了这个圈子。
And we, yes, we're all doing that.
而我们，是的，我们都在这么做。
And then we put it on the show.
然后我们把它放到了节目里。
And now here it is, like, you know, during a birth story of someone's first moment in the world.
现在它就在这里，就像，你知道的，在某个人的生命中的第一个时刻的出生故事期间。
Do you know what I, it's not so much catch raises or runners, but there's certain things that I think about that I think are so smart.
你知道吗，我，倒不是什么口头禅或常青话题，但有些事情我想起来，觉得真是太聪明了。
And we haven't even gotten close to this episode.
而且我们甚至还没讲到这一集。
I don't know where this episode is.
我不知道这一集在哪里。
But the one where James Vanderbeek played Robin's like high school crush, like her boyfriend, right?
但詹姆斯·范德比克饰演罗宾的高中暗恋对象，也就是她的男友那一集，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
The idea that like, if you loved someone when you're 14, 15, 16, no matter what they become or how they look later in life, you will continue, your heart will pound when you see them.
那种观点是，如果你在14、15、16岁时爱过某个人，无论他们后来变成什么样，或者外表如何，你都会继续，当你看到他们时，你的心依然会砰砰直跳。
You know, like they will continue to be the, and I just thought that was such a smart observation about youth and like first love and how, like there's certain things like that that come back to me.
你知道的，他们会一直是那个……我只是觉得这是对青春和初恋的一个多么精妙的观察，以及有些这样的事情是如何再次回到我身边的。
And I think, God, that was smart.
我想，天哪，这太精妙了。
Yeah, my most recent thing like that, it's kind of the same theme, and I've, was it literally the same episode?
是的，我最近经历的最类似的事情，其实是差不多的主题，而且我——难道真的是同一集吗？
Revert a go?
回退到过去（Revertigo）？
Is that, was that in that episode?
是吗，那是那一集吗？
Oh yeah, what was that?
哦，对，那是什么？
What was that?
那是什么？
Senior moment.
老年时刻。
The idea that old people from your past bring out a completely old version of you, it just comes back out, like Lily just, like completely reverts when this friend of hers comes from her past.
那种观点是，你过去的那些老熟人会激发出你身上一个完全过去的版本，它就这样重新冒出来了，就像莉莉一样，当她过去的这个朋友出现时，她整个人完全回退了。
I think it might have been that same episode.
我觉得可能就是同一集。
How many moment?
有什么时刻？
Like we brought out something different in this head, yeah.
就像我们在这种状态下激发出了完全不同的东西，是的。
I thought of it recently because I've had a couple times, 50 now and I've had a couple of times where I hung out with people from my 20s and 30s.
我最近想到了这一点，因为我有几次经历，现在50岁了，有几次我和20多岁和30多岁时的朋友一起出去玩。
I mean, went out and like had a big drinking night, a big drinking night is a lot less than it used to be for me, but it still like doesn't take much.
我是说，出去像以前那样痛饮了一场，虽然现在的痛饮对我来说比以前少多了，但其实也用不着喝多少。
And the way I felt sick for like 72 hours after like my revert ago, it was like, oh, well, party like we used to.
我在我的“回退时刻”之后难受了整整72小时的那种感觉，就像是，噢，好吧，像以前那样狂欢吧。
Oh God, it's so bad.
噢天哪，太糟糕了。
It's been hurt so much.
难受得要命。
And I remember in like a three day hangover after one of those nights, I thought it was revert ago.
我记得在经历过那种夜晚之一后的三天宿醉里，我心想这就是回退时刻。
The revert ago did me in.
回退时刻把我给害惨了。
I acted like I just was 28 again, and guess what, I'm 50.
我表现得就像自己才28岁一样，而你猜怎么着，我50岁了。
So that was my most recent hymiumism that came into my head.
所以这就是我脑子里最近浮现的那个老梗。
I was like, I should know better.
我当时想：我本该更懂事的。
Yeah.
是的。
And this old man, he busted me, fell in love with you, knew where you were sitting.
这个老头子，他把我抓了个正着，爱上了你，还知道你当时坐在哪儿。
And now, commercials.
现在，广告。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈尔德曼，“超量修复”播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会接听听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，却害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我在倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么问题，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的“超量修复”播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在各大播客平台或访问 HyperFixedPod.com 找到它。
of commercials, back to Shell.
广告结束，回到谢尔（Shell）的话题。
Sis- uh, sorry, Sis-a-li-sorrow says, I'm skipping class right now so I could watch this, so.
Sis——哦，抱歉，Sis-a-li-sorrow 说，我正逃课来看这个直播，所以。
We approve.
我们批准了。
We'll write you a note.
我们给你写张请假条。
Okay, um, I'm gonna say that for the end.
好吧，嗯，我要把这个留到最后再说。
Um, we've gone over this a little bit on the show, Craig, but I know people always are curious.
嗯，我们在节目里稍微讨论过这个了，克雷格，但我知道大家总是很好奇。
And how did you manage playing cards for life asks?
那么你们是如何处理那些长线埋伏的剧情的呢？
How did you guys track all the little details and stories happening over all the years and always impress me, especially those long term payoffs?
你们是怎么追踪多年来发生的那些细枝末节和故事，并且总是能惊艳到我，尤其是那些长期的伏笔回收？
If you could say a little about that and about, I would say like, what's the on balance?
如果你能稍微谈谈那个，我想说，总的来说情况是怎样的？
How many things were long term payoffs that you really planted or that you years later were like, Hey, here's an idea of how to bring something back.
有多少事情是你们真正精心策划的长期伏笔，或者是多年后你们觉得，嘿，这里有个把某些东西串联回来的主意？
We never plan not bringing back.
我们从来没有计划不去回收它们。
Right.
对吧。
A lot of the long-term payoffs were planned.
很多长期的伏笔都是计划好的。
We love that kind of long-term thinking, but then we would like fuck up the sofa, right?
我们喜欢那种长远规划，但有时候我们也会把沙发给搞砸，对吧？
From the end of season one of beginning of season two, the sofa changes in the span of 30 seconds, and you'd be like, oh yeah, we forgot about that.
从第一季末到第二季初，沙发在30秒内就变了，然后你会觉得，哦对，我们把这事忘了。
We're planning something that's going to pay off in season four, so that'll be cool.
我们在筹划一些要在第四季才回收的东西，所以那会很酷。
And I think we were maybe better at some of the long-term stuff than occasionally screwing up something like fumbling a really easy pass.
而且我觉得我们处理某些长期伏笔可能还行，但偶尔也会把事情搞砸，比如把一个极其简单的传球给弄丢了。
We would go for like the Hail Mary, but like, you know, ADR touchdown pass and fumble like the little handoff.
我们本来想打那种绝杀球，比如，你知道的，像美式足球里的达阵传球，结果却把一个简单的小手递手传球给弄 fumble（掉球）了。
And like we had a funny record of sometimes screwing up very easy things.
而且我们经常有把非常简单的事情给搞砸的搞笑纪录。
But yeah, a lot of those long-term things were planned.
但没错，许多长期的东西确实是计划好的。
We kept our writers assistants kept a running list of like things that we planted that we have to pay off later.
我们的编剧助理们保留了一份进行中的清单，记录着我们埋下的、以后必须回收的梗。
And that was like a running file in the writers room.
这就像是编剧室里的一个常设档案。
And sometimes we'd write something up on a board to remember it, you know, future selves.
有时候我们会把一些东西写在黑板上以提醒自己，你知道的，留给未来的我们。
We have to pay this off at the end of the season.
我们必须在季末把这个伏笔收回来。
Sometimes we'd not think of it at all ahead of time and we'd just realize, wait, we can kind of retroactively create a set up payoff situation if we do X, Y, and Z.
有时我们压根没提前想过，只是突然意识到，等等，如果我们做X、Y和Z，我们就可以某种程度上事后追溯地创造出一个“埋伏笔-回收伏笔”的情境。
And we always loved when things echoed and resonated and came back around, even in this conversation and this IG Live of this today's episode is like, every, there's so many things in life that have set ups and payoffs, even if they only make sense later.
我们总是喜欢那些遥相呼应、产生共鸣并最终回环的时刻，甚至就像在这场对话、这个今天的Instagram直播节目中一样，生活中有很多事情都有着伏笔与回收，哪怕它们只有在事后才说得通。
And one thing, the dominoes kind of fall in a certain way and you look back and you go, how did they fall exactly that way and it changed my life?
某件事，多米诺骨牌以某种特定方式倒下了，你回过头去看，会说，它们怎么就偏偏那样倒下了，还改变了我的人生？
And so, yes, you have to, sometimes you plan those things, but sometimes you just, you go with them, you stumble upon it and you go, great, that's gonna make us look smart if we own that and retroactively create a payoff to something.
所以，是的，有时候你必须计划这些事情，但有时候你只是顺其自然，偶然碰上了，然后觉得，太好了，如果我们把这事认领下来，并为某种我们甚至没打算当成伏笔的东西事后补上一个回收，这会显得我们很聪明。
We didn't even mean as a setup.
我们甚至一开始没把它当成铺垫。
Josh, we've got a message to you, by the way, just say hello to Delson.
乔希，顺便说一句，我们收到了一条给你的消息，向迪尔森（Delson）问好。
I hope he's not too jealous of the baby.
我希望他对这个婴儿没有太嫉妒。
Oh, good question.
哦，好问题。
He's adjusting.
他在适应。
I mean, he's not like a, he's not a brat, you know, So he's not gonna, but he's got a little more of a hanggog lookin' inside.
我是说，他不是那种，他不是个被宠坏的小屁孩，你知道的，所以他不会，但他看起来稍微有点闷闷不乐。
We went out for a family walk this morning and took the ball and we're throwing it in the park and he was, you know, he was having a great time.
我们今天早上出去进行了一场家庭散步，带了球，在公园里扔着玩，他当时，你知道的，玩得可开心了。
So I think we just need to, we always try to remind ourselves like, like Nelson needs.
所以我想我们只需要，我们总是试图提醒自己，就像，纳尔逊需要的。
He was our only child for a while, you know?
他有一段时间是我们唯一的孩子，你知道的？
Yeah.
是的。
Dominic, and another ongoing theme of today, Dominic Borboa says, I'm skipping, I'm skipping my online karate class for this.
多米尼克，今天另一个持续的主题，多米尼克·博尔博阿（Dominic Borboa）说，我为了看这个跳过了我的在线空手道课。
Everything about that.
关于这句话的一切。
That raises more questions than it answers, but I like it.
这引发的问题比它解答的还要多，但我喜欢。
But I like it.
但我喜欢。
We can guide you through some karate to close.
我们可以在结尾时带你们做一些空手道动作。
Why don't we just, let's just do some slow elegant movements.
为什么我们不，我们来做一些缓慢优雅的动作吧。
Everyone can probably use a little bit of a physical.
每个人大概都能受益于一点身体活动。
Between the two of us, we can come up with some karate on the fly, right?
我们俩凑在一起，随时都能即兴想出几招空手道，对吧？
Jonathan Zubia wants us to know that he found a baby bird in the alley.
乔纳森·祖比亚（Jonathan Zubia）想让我们知道他在小巷里发现了一只幼鸟。
There might be some slim pickings on this week's.
本周的内容可能会有些乏善可陈。
Is that, cause that, cause there's a photo that accompanies that statement, don't open an alley.
那是，因为那，因为那句话后面附带了一张照片，别打开小巷。
Cause that's definitely a dong.
因为那绝对是个老二梗。
That is a hundred percent a dong reference.
那百分之百是个老二梗。
That's a punchy dong reference, if I ever heard one.
如果我这辈子听过的话，这就是个犀利的老二梗。
and well-played sir, but please don't send the photo.
干得漂亮，先生，但请别发照片。
Oh, we've been asked about any progress on the people will dance merch.
哦，有人问起“人们会跳舞”周边商品（People Will Dance merch）的进展。
Oh.
哦。
We love this idea, don't we?
我们很喜欢这个主意，对吧？
We do.
是的。
Let's work this out right here on the pod.
让我们就在播客里把这事敲定吧。
Craig, what do we think the legal ramifications are of us creating progress?
克雷格，你觉得我们搞点新进展会有什么法律后果？
Yes, it's always good to be recording your conversations about legal things.
没错，把你们讨论法律问题的对话录下来总是挺好的。
So this is on the record between the three of us.
所以这是我们三个人之间正式记录在案的。
And however many people are listening.
还有不知道多少正在收听的听众。
My lawyer is furiously texting me not to answer that question, Alex, so I'm gonna...
我的律师正疯狂发信息让我别回答那个问题，亚历克斯，所以我打算……
It'd be hilarious if they shut us down for taking three common words from one episode of a show.
如果我们因为用了某集剧里的三个常用词而被勒令停播，那可就太搞笑了吧。
They're like, no, Disney owns that phrase.
他们会说，不，迪士尼拥有那个短语的版权。
Like, what a weird thing.
天哪，多奇怪的事啊。
Yeah.
是啊。
Yeah, I mean, people will dance from the pilot of How I Met Your Mother, where Ted is being asked, you know, Marshall has just gotten engaged to Lilly, and he says, look, it's not like I, you know, think about my wedding all the time, and then he goes into this incredibly detailed list of what he needs from his wedding, which culminates in Band-No DJ.
对啊，我是说，人们会从《老爸老妈浪漫史》试播集里想起那个情节，当时泰德被问到——你知道的，马歇尔刚和莉莉订婚，他说，听着，这可不是说我，你知道的，整天都在想我的婚礼，然后他就开始列出一份极其详尽的清单，列出他婚礼上需要的东西，最后以“要乐队不要DJ”达到高潮。
People will dance.
人们会跳舞的。
I'm not going to worry about it.
我才不担心这个呢。
And I shared that this had become a kind of mantra for me of like, faith that things will work out.
我分享过，这句话已经成了我的某种座右铭，代表着相信事情总会顺利解决。
Like, people will dance.
就像，人们会跳舞。
I don't have to stress a bit, I don't have to sweat over it, I don't have to worry about it.
我一点也不用感到压力，不用为之焦虑，不用为之担心。
And I've had a number of people say they either got a tattooed or they'll come up to me at a show and say, well, you write people will dance so I can get a tattoo.
有好几个人跟我说，他们要么去纹了这个身，要么在见面会上跑来对我说，嘿，你写了“人们会跳舞”，所以我可以去纹个身。
And then we came up with this idea that we wanted to do some merch that just said people will dance.
然后我们想到了这个主意，我们想做一些周边商品，上面就印着“人们会跳舞”。
And it's very, if you know, you know.
而且这很符合“懂的自然懂”。
But also there's something about the phrase itself, people will dance that is like inherently makes you feel good and optimistic, right?
但同时，这个短语本身——“人们会跳舞”，有种天然能让人感觉良好且乐观的魔力，对吧？
Like, people will dance.
就像，人们会跳舞。
Like dancing is a sign of exuberance and joy and it's gonna happen.
跳舞是充满激情和欢乐的象征，而且它一定会发生。
So.
所以。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, let's talk.
好吧，我们商量一下。
I'll get it.
我去处理。
We'll talk to John Morrow about the font.
我们要跟约翰·莫罗聊聊字体的事。
Let's hope it's not people will sue if we make you sure it's.
但愿如果我们真做了，不会变成“人们会起诉”吧。
I think also, and Josh, you've mentioned this on the podcast that you created at one of your company, you named it your neighbor company, People Dance.
我觉得还有一点，乔什，你之前在播客里提到过，你创办的其中一家公司，你把它命名为你的邻居公司——“人们跳舞”。
I feel like that gives us legal, legal footing.
我觉得这给了我们法律上的依据。
Yeah, it's if you're a fan of my corporation You want to wear a shirt that shouts it out, yeah Alec you're not a lawyer correct.
对啊，如果你是我公司的粉丝，你想穿一件能大声喊出这一点的衬衫，行啊。亚历克斯，你可不是个律师，对吧。
You're not in fact a lawyer.
你事实上并不是个律师。
So we're not I just want not a good lawyer.
所以我们不——我只是想说，我可不是个好律师。
Let me tell you that By the way mark rampage shut out to to mark who says I'm in my film class watching this Well, we can't film that can we we can't encourage that kind of rap scallion re Yeah.
顺便说一句，马克·兰帕吉，向马克致敬，他说：“我在电影课上看着这个呢。”好吧，我们可不能拍那个，对吧？我们不能鼓励那种淘气行为，耶。
We're honored.
我们深感荣幸。
And as we close this out, I always like to find two sort of bigger questions here.
在节目接近尾声时，我总是喜欢提出两个稍微宏大一点的问题。
So let's go with this one, which is Elizabeth G.
那就选这个吧，伊丽莎白·G·韦尔汉姆问：
Wareham asks, what is surprised you all the most about re-watching the show so far?
到目前为止，重看这部剧最让你们感到惊讶的是什么？
I would say just how good it is.
我可以说，仅仅是它有多好看。
Like I had a you know if you if you've listened to me on other podcasts or even listen to this podcast you'll know that I had and continue to have although it's really dimming considerably a somewhat conflicted relationship with um being conflated with a character or being called a character's name that's not my real name like me being very clear that I'm an actor playing a role but other people saying like you are this person and you have to be this person and I refuse to accept you as anyone but this person and it was all very uh in terms of identity it was very destabilizing.
就像我曾经——你知道的，如果你在其他播客里听过我说话，甚至听过这个播客，你就会知道，我过去曾经、并且现在依然（尽管已经大大减弱了）与以下情况保持着某种矛盾的关系：那就是我被和一个角色混为一谈，或者被叫着某个角色的名字而不是我真正的名字。我很清楚自己是一个扮演角色的演员，但其他人却说“你就是这个人，你必须是这个人，我拒绝承认你是除了这个人以外的任何其他人”。这一切——在身份认同方面——非常具有颠覆性。
And so I think psychologically I had to create some, I was trying to create some distance between myself and the show and I forgot that it was a really good show.
所以我认为在心理上，我不得不创造一些距离，我试图在自己和这部剧之间拉开距离，而我却忘记了这是一部非常优秀的剧。
And I forgot that people love it for a reason.
我忘记了人们喜欢它是有原因的。
And you know, I didn't even watch all the episodes when they were on the air.
而且你知道，当年播出时我甚至没有看完所有的集数。
I probably saw like 40, 45 percent of the episodes like throughout the run.
在整部剧播出的过程中，我大概只看了40%、45%的集数。
So I'm seeing some of these episodes for the first time and I'm able to all these years later You're somewhat dispassionately watch it and objectively see that this was a great show that I was a part of.
所以有些剧集我是第一次看，多年后的今天，我能够以一种相对抽离的心态去观看它，并客观地看到这是一部我曾参与其中的伟大作品。
I'm really proud to be a part of the show.
我为能参与这部剧感到非常骄傲。
My wife even said that when, how I met your mother fans, come up to me and want to talk about the show, she said, since you've been doing the podcast, you're a lot warmer.
我妻子甚至说过，当《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝走过来想跟我聊这部剧时，她说：“自从你开始做这个播客以来，你温和多了。”
And I think it's also because I understand what they're enthusiastic about.
我想这也是因为我理解他们的热情所在。
And I'm not thinking that they're assaulting me or being, you know, making me, putting me in some strange box.
而且我不觉得他们在攻击我，或者把我塞进什么奇怪的框框里。
They just want to talk about this thing that I was a part of that they really love.
他们只是想聊聊我曾经参与过、他们也深爱着的这部作品。
So I've been able to become a fan of the show, which is a very cool thing, and it's really helped contextualize the show in my life as this really special thing that I was a part of and not something I need to run away from, but something I can fully embrace.
所以我能够成为这部剧的粉丝，这是一件很酷的事，这真的帮我把这部剧在我的生命中定性为一件我曾参与过的非常特别的事，而不是一件我想逃避的事，而是一件我可以完全拥抱的事。
Yeah, I'm so happy for you that you are getting that.
是的，我真为你能有这种感受感到高兴。
I'm so happy for you.
我太为你高兴了。
I really am.
我是认真的。
You deserve to feel that.
你配得上这种感觉。
You were really good on that really good show, and my answer is the same answer.
你在那部非常优秀的剧里表现得很好，我的回答也是一样的。
sweating over every detail in the moment 20 years ago, 15 years ago, you know, all through that whole the whole show.
20年前、15年前，在当时对每一个细节都绞尽脑汁，你知道的，贯穿整部剧的始终。
And then looking back at these episodes, and I'm not worried about the sound mix, I'm not worried about whether scene six had a good enough blow at the end of the scene.
而现在回看这些剧集，我不再担心混音效果，也不再担心第六场结尾的包袱抖得够不够好。
I'm not worried about, wait, oh, I did is the C story.
我不担心，等等，哦，我做的是C线剧情。
I'll blow as a joke at the end of the scene.
我会在场景结尾时把包袱当笑话抖出来。
It's coming to me, please don't sue me.
我会想出来的，求求别告我。
I'm not creating an answer and say work environment here.
我可不是在这里营造什么充满压力的工作环境。
And, you know, I'm not obsessed with I just think that C-story in that one episode wasn't as good as it could have been.
而且，你知道的，我不会纠结于我觉得那一集里的C线剧情本可以更好这种事。
No, it just, all of that's gone.
不，这一切都烟消云散了。
And even if I see something, I could, that could have been better.
就算我看到了什么本可以更好的地方。
It's like, it's so, it's not even a blip on the radar for me now, the spirit of the show.
这就好像，这甚至算不上我现在的雷达上的一个小波澜，这就是这部剧的精神。
I watch the show and I feel it's spirit and it's energy and it's heart.
我看这部剧，我能感受到它的精神、它的活力和它的核心。
It feels like something that is its own thing.
它感觉像是一个独立的存在。
It's not my identity is not writing on it.
我的身份没有押注在它上面。
Your identity is not writing on it.
你的身份也没有押注在它上面。
It just is this thing in the world that really belongs to the fans now.
它现在就是世界上真正属于粉丝们的这样一件东西。
And we get to watch it kind of as fans now too.
而我们现在也得以像粉丝一样去观看它。
And that's wonderful.
这太棒了。
And also not breaking it apart into small pieces with which we obsessively examine each piece, even though we're kind of doing that on the show, but really, we made a nine-year movie.
而且也不用把它拆成小块去拼命审视每一个碎片，尽管我们在节目里其实有点在这么做，但说实话，我们拍了一部长达九年的电影。
Like we made this big, huge, sprawling story that people just love and watch over and over and over again and give them so much comfort and joy.
就像我们制作了一个宏大、庞大、漫长的故事，人们就是喜欢它，一遍又一遍地看，并从中获得极大的安慰和快乐。
And I just feel like there's something about looking at it as a big, almost like a triptych or something like a story that winds around all the walls and you just move from panel to panel.
我只是觉得，把这部剧看作是一个整体，几乎就像一个三联画什么的，或者像一个盘旋在所有墙壁上的故事，你只需要从一个画面走到另一个画面，这种感觉真的很奇妙。
There's, yeah.
有，是的。
Yeah, and it doesn't live or die on one of those panels.
是的，它不会因为其中某一个画面而成功或失败。
It is the whole thing.
它是一个完整的整体。
And I see it as the whole thing now.
我现在把它看作是一个完整的整体。
And that is a great feeling and it's not one that I fully had at the time.
这感觉太棒了，我在当年并没有完全拥有这种感受。
Well, for final word here, just for you Josh, Barry Likumahua says, by the way, Josh, we missed Jordan's questions and observations, We should good health for Jordana and the baby.
好的，最后说一句，乔治，巴里·利库马胡阿（Barry Likumahua）说，顺便问一下，乔治，我们错过了乔丹（Jordan）的问题和看法，我们应该祝乔达娜（Jordana）和宝宝身体健康。
Jordana is the most popular part of this podcast.
乔达娜是这个播客中最受欢迎的部分。
That's what we've learned.
这就是我们所了解到的。
She's killing her her IG live right now.
她现在正大获成功地开着IG直播。
Like she always, that's such a power move.
就像她一直以来那样，这真是一记大招。
She always launches a cock eating at you.
她总是挑我们吃饭的时候开播。
It's obnoxious that she schedules them at the exact same time as ours.
她把直播时间定得跟我们一模一样，这太讨厌了。
And that it's double the number of viewers, listeners.
而且观众和听众人数是我们的两倍。
That's heartbreaking to us.
这让我们很心碎。
Now, Jordana is great.
不过，乔达娜真的很棒。
She has been busy with this little human.
她最近一直在忙这个小人类。
Yeah.
是的。
So there is that.
所以就是这样。
We're trying to pull her out of retirement.
我们正试图把她从“退休”状态中拉回来。
Yeah.
是的。
But I'm so glad people loved her questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met a mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
不过我很高兴大家喜欢一个从未看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》的临床心理学家的提问和观察，而她同时也是乔什的妻子。
With a catchy name like that, how can we not bring that segment back?
顶着这样一个吸引人的名字，我们怎么能不把这个环节带回来呢？
I know.
我知道。
But we've heard so consistently from people who miss it.
但我们不断听到有人说他们很想念这个环节。
Oh my God.
天哪。
Every time.
每次都是。
Every week.
每周都是。
Yeah.
对。
So I'll pass on the garage.
所以我就不提那个车库了。
She'll be, she's very touched by it.
她会，她对此非常感动。
And that message from Barry says, wishing good health for Jordana and the baby from Indonesia.
巴里发来的那条消息说：来自印度尼西亚的祝福，祝乔丹娜和宝宝身体健康。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Beautiful.
太美好了。
It's nice.
真好。
Alec, I couldn't help notice we didn't hear from Eliza, who claims she was named after my grandmother Rose.
亚历克，我忍不住注意到我们没听到伊丽莎的声音，她声称自己是以我祖母罗斯的名字命名的。
It's not an entry line if we don't get one of those comments.
如果没有这样的评论，那就不算是一条入场台词了。
Where is Eliza Rose?
伊丽莎·罗斯在哪里？
But never the answer.
但从来没有答案。
Never the answer to what it means.
对于这到底意味着什么，从来没有答案。
All right, it's going to keep going.
好吧，这还会继续下去。
It's a serious long mystery, maybe at the end of the podcast.
这是一个漫长的未解之谜，也许会在播客快结束时揭晓。
And an answer to several people's questions.
以及对多个人提出的问题的回答。
Yes, the audio from what you've just experienced will be available as a podcast episode.
是的，你们刚刚经历的这段音频将作为一集播客发布。
Several, I want to say months from now, weeks, months from now.
我想说，大约在几个月、几周，几个月之后吧。
So this will be here.
所以这个会保留的。
So if your question was asked and you want to prove that to other folks, it will be recorded, and you will have access to that in hell of a month.
因此，如果你的问题被问到了，并且你想向其他人证明这一点，它会被录下来，而且在一个多月后你就能听到它。
So that's our Instagram live for today.
这就是我们今天的 Instagram 直播。
Thanks everybody.
谢谢大家。
Have a great time.
祝大家玩得开心。
Thank you so much for tuning in.
非常感谢大家的收看。
and if you're loving the podcast, please spread the word.
如果你喜欢这个播客，请帮忙宣传一下。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please acquit me.
请宣判我无罪吧。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都可以被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我是怎么成为你妈妈的》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人，由 Office Ladies Network 和 Audacy 联合呈献和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集的执行制片人还有珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matata.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫制作和剪辑，我们的联合制作人是道格·马塔塔。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯。
Our digital content producer, AKA Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，也就是 Z 世代大师，是艾米莉·布隆伯格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
插图由约翰·莫罗创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《纽约市》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供伴奏音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢罗拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，并点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
欢迎在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的时事通讯，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐及其他作品。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
在各大图书销售渠道订购克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作《事情可不是这样的》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他的其他已发表作品。
And you can subscribe to my own dead father's society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的“死去的父亲协会”。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关本节目为先天性小儿心脏病研究筹款的长期活动如何发挥作用的更多信息，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。
Real question, it just hit me, or just New York City.
有个真正的问题，我刚想到的，还是说只是纽约市。